[MUSIC PLAYING]
Eventbrite is a
ticketing platform.
We help event
organizers sell tickets,
and we help event attendees.
We help consumers find great
things happening around them.
We think about ourselves, not
as this monolithic ticketing
machine or beast, but
really as a platform where
you can build off
and innovate and do
so many different
creative things with that.
So we've actually
opened up our platform.
We've developed an API
that we have actually
thousands of developers
helping to expand our platform
and bring us into new
directions, new geographies,
and new categories
through this platform.
We've also just
tried to solve a lot
of the different hard problems
of what events, as a consumer,
I'd like to attend.
How do you make algorithmic
recommendations?
How do you stop
fraudsters that are
trying to run money
through the system?
How do you make this
big shift to mobile
and really embrace
the revolution that's
happening on Android
to move ticketing
from this physical paper
ticket onto your mobile phone?
So there's just a myriad
of different challenges
and hard problems to solve.